this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the first session in our
autumn 2012 series of the general title
for the series as topics and
international technology management and
this year our focus is going to be on
green technologies and transportation
especially what's happening in Asia new
developments from Asia so I'm going to
give the leadoff talk today and I have
some information about subsequent talks
in this series as we go along of start
off with some welcome comments and about
taking the course for credit if you're a
Stanford student also then talk about
green technologies and transportation
looking at kind of from materials to
systems to actual usage areas and
including the current situation in major
Asian markets um look at a couple of
areas in which Asia has already taken
the lead in terms of green
transportation technologies and a little
bit of information on some policies and
investment plans and finally I think
we'll have some time for discussion at
the end of the session today I look
forward to your comments as well so this
is a weekly public lecture series public
is important because it's open to
everybody we want to welcome everyone
who is here no matter whether you're a
Stanford student other member of the
Stanford community or whether you're
just coming in from outside or somehow
you heard about this and so you're going
to watch on youtube we want to welcome
everybody to participate in this it's
every thursday beginning today except
for thanksgiving day through december
the six this year and i want to thank
the alan minor foundation for giving us
some additional financial support of
this series this is one reason that we
can put some refreshments out of every
week at the end of the session so that
we can all network out in the foyer out
there so each week some guest speaker is
going to be bringing in an up-to-date
view about how business and technology
intersex not purely research not purely
business but how the two intersect in
regard to an important you know this
important area for growth we try to
bring in fresh content from Asia that
people here might not have heard about
otherwise recent programs in this series
I'm actually rather proud that it seems
like everybody else in the valley is
doing mobile internet this year because
we did it last year and we've looked at
energy and cleantech before in 2010 we
once in a while we'll do some technology
strategies or a kind of more sort of
structural changes between Asia and the
rest of the world the slides from these
sessions most of them are available on
our website so if you have an interest
in any of these topics go take a look
and see often our speakers have allowed
us to post their slides on our website
own I want to have a special note
depending on how you count this is our
20th anniversary for putting on these
series started off in 1992 with a
special series that was really taught by
Professor Fumio kodama who at the time
was one of the Guru's of technology
management and you know since then the
beginning with the following year we
started to have a specific thematic a
kind of focus for each one of the series
oh and you know we've been able to scoop
various things while we've been doing
these Oh back in 1995 we got Shuji
Nakamura to give a presentation on his
research into the blue LED before the
blue laser was announced and in fact at
dinner that night with him and a
well-known professor Jim Harris I think
I can say this now it's 1995
we're sitting around at dinner and
professor Harris says well if you've got
this and this in this kind of
performance this thing must lays and dr.
nakamora got real you know step back
real quickly and said don't tell anybody
we haven't announced it yet so we've
been able to do that we've been able to
have some new product launches besides
that reflective LCD projector we were
the first place in the world where sharp
showed its 20 inch back in those days 20
inch flat panel display right so we've
been doing these a long time oh we have
added a spring series from 1995 that's
kind of really currently dormant it's
morphing into a smaller series for new
PhD students about how to have an impact
with your research and then we've also
added a series on entrepreneurship in
Asia that from 2003 so welcome to our
20th anniversary series it is available
to Stanford students for credit there's
no prerequisites it's opened all
undergraduates and graduates you can
repeat this series for credit because
the content is different each time but
remember it is a seminar and there are
limits by a lot of degree programs on
how many seminars you can count toward
any degree requirement oh we're very
happy to have casual attendance by
students open to the public nobody needs
to tell us in advance but we're
delighted to see everybody and we will
have refreshments afterward I'd like to
encourage you especially to meet people
that you don't already know it's great
for me to look around the auditorium and
see people that I've known for years and
some new faces but if you're a student
find out who these visitors are get to
find out why they're here and how they
found out about the series and what
they're really interested in and
conversely for you folks in industry
please find out what our students are
interested in I'd like to see the two
communities interact more with
each other so if you are a Stanford
student please get a syllabus this is
our official agreement with you about
what the requirements for credit are
basically there are two requirements for
credit you must be here at the
auditorium for seven out of the nine
sessions um if you're registered through
the Stanford center for professional
development and we get a list from SCPD
about who's registered through them
within a few weeks then this requirement
of course is waived they the expectation
is that you're watching online the
second requirement is for everybody
students to submit a comment or summary
of each week's session for eight out of
the nine sessions your comment is due
within two weeks of today if you're
going to comment on today's session of
course you can take one week as an
excused absence about 60 words just a
couple of paragraphs please don't write
a whole lot but the pedagogical value
behind this is that if you actually put
something together and write something
back to me after having watched the
session you get a lot more about it it
really pulls the whole you know hour and
50 minutes back into your consciousness
and if you're going to have trouble
fulfilling either one of these
requirements because of something
happening getting sick or whatever
please send me an email we can usually
work out some sort of a makeup
assignment alright so today one more
request please be sure and fill out the
survey that's being passed out if you're
a student registering for credit this
will be the record of your attendance
today so that's very important otherwise
we won't know that you're fulfilling the
on-site attendance reddit own and
everybody else please let us know what
you're thinking we've got some spaces on
the back of the forum for you to tell us
what you're interested in and
all very much try to bend the series to
the interest that you have oh okay so
let's talk about the greening of
transportation if my clicker will work
okay um first kind of data point that I
want to give to you is how the world's
energy consumption has grown since
between 1973 and 2009 the total final
consumption TFC grew from four thousand
million tonnes of oil equivalent to
eight thousand million tonnes of oil
equivalent during that period of time it
doubled right out of that amount back in
1973 fossil fuels accounted for of 3500
million tonne equivalent the percentage
of fossil fuels overall is less now
right fossil fuels accounted for 5500
million tonnes of oil equivalent but if
you look at transportation you see that
almost all of the fuel used in
transportation sector is fossil fuel
this is an issue because of the rapid
economic growth of Asia so total fuel
consumption fossil fuel consumption grew
at fifty-seven percent right and the
worldwide energy consumption grew at
seventy-eight percent but transportation
itself is growing as more rapidly and
you know in the United States
transportation currently accounts for
about twenty eight percent of all energy
use think about China it's still only
twenty percent of all energy use in
China if you look region by region at
this 1973 to 2009 comparison you see how
the OECD share advanced countries went
down from sixty percent to less than
fifty percent and of course the two
sectors that are noticeable by there
growth or China and Asia and in this
case Asia excludes China right this is
other Asia oh so total final energy
consumption went from eight percent to
seventeen percent in China and from six
percent to twelve percent in Asia the
other downside of this though is that
regional shares of world's carbon
dioxide emissions show an even greater
increase for China and Asia China went
up from five point seven percent to
twenty three point seven percent during
this time period and the rest of Asia
went up from three percent to ten
percent 10.9 percent during that time
period now this is of course a concern
right the Asia share of total energy use
has gone up by a hundred nineteen
percent but the Asia share of carbon
dioxide emissions has gone up by three
hundred and fifteen percent this is not
a good pattern right go ahead CSE my
kids said the year nineteen
seventy-three like what do you and I was
too because I had good data sources for
those years I was in about nineteen
about 2009 that's an issue is that
worldwide consumption was dampened a
little bit by the 2008 Lehman Brothers
shock but I'm you know I will be honest
and say that I pulled this out of a
source that picked those two years and
that was the most recent data I could
get on this too okay good question other
comments okay so you know by 2009 Asia
including China the two sectors added up
account for about a third of all of the
world's co2 emissions now co2 is not the
only greenhouse gas
but this is certainly one of the major
factors that is influencing climate
change and so you know people are very
concerned with the role of the
transportation sector in creating
greenhouse gas interesting data point in
2009 China passed the US and became the
world's biggest auto market there were
170 million cars on the road in China in
2009 and they're expecting to add more
than 220 million cars by 2020 similarly
total freight transport in China has
grown by about a hundred and fifty
percent between 2000 and 2008 and I did
intentionally put 2008 because the u.s.
total number in 2009 was actually lower
than the number in 2008 but you know us
had seven point four percent growth in
terms of ton miles or metric ton
kilometers of freight traffic Oh whereas
in China the number is one hundred and
fifty percent needless to say trucks are
not nearly as clean as cars and cars are
not nearly as clean as electric vehicles
so China's very aware of this oh really
when we've talking about green
technologies first thing to remember is
this is a relative term right i think it
was completely green but it's the use of
technologies processes or approach
approaches say to supply chain
management that will reduce negative
environmental impact or possibly improve
environmental sustainability in
comparison to traditional approaches so
there are other terms that are very
similar you will hear these called
environmental technologies but that kind
of misses the fact that you know as a
battery technology and environmental
technology maybe you don't immediately
think of that
cleantech is a term that's often used
here I tend to use the term cleantech
for green technologies that make a
profit that's the way that the clean
tech forum tends to describe clean tech
clean technologies as really an approach
to business that will be good business
as well as environmentally sustainable
so we're primarily interested in kind of
the technology management side here oh
yeah and the whole thing in
transportation has really involved round
reducing greenhouse gases and also
reducing energy which are of course
related so if you look at this in the
transportation sector this is a slide
I'd like for you to think about some
because you have several different
levels of Technology all the way up from
enabling technologies like materials and
components through the vehicle systems
themselves the fuels that the vehicles
will use the energy storage techniques
that they use then you have the whole
kind of system level that the vehicles
are put inside and finally above the
system's level structure you actually
have the use of the system how you
encourage people to stop using
automobiles and encourage them to switch
to public transportation or as is the
case with Stanford's Capri program right
encouraging people to use their cars at
different times of the day so is to
reduce congestion on the roads um so I
guess the classic kind of green
technology and transportation is the
electric vehicle right but there are
also electric buses electric bicycles
once in a while you see people coming up
with an idea for some sort of a
superlight airplane um improving the
efficiency of vehicles has been a major
step forward even for gasoline-powered
vehicles using new information
technology energy scavenging
technologies that allow you to charge up
the battery when you put on the brake
um new kinds of powertrain technologies
so one interesting difference between an
electric car and a gasoline cars the
electric car typically does not need a
transmission you just run the electric
motor at 14,000 RPM or whatever and it's
not particularly unhappy um so improving
efficiency and also in regard to vehicle
technologies we should look at a mission
scrubbing how people are trying to take
the bad stuff out of the emissions of
the cars that not only cars but also
ships and airplanes and so forth with
fuels this is where we also get into
battery technologies and biofuels fuel
cells Oh looking at total systems
intelligent transportation systems were
all the rage here for a while but they
sort of disappeared there's some work at
Berkeley going on but i think that
there's a lot more work going on in this
sector in asia Oh logistics how an
airline can improve its total carbon
footprint footprint by things that does
on the ground as well as things that it
does in the air and then finally you
know the systems use function so please
consider the whole system in this
quarter we will only be able to have
some representative presentations we
won't be able to cover all of this but
hopefully as we go along we'll pick up
some of the Holts that we may not be
able to get to so it's not like Asia's
unaware of the problem go ahead I would
ask about until you're covering here
specifically including the last slide
yeah there's been a lot of talk about
green washing that I've heard recently
in some countries in the world would
definitely be Sudanese assignment woods
we definitely disagree with this I think
Denmark has a law that will not allow
anyone to say something is green it
doesn't actually
give a substantial impact on the
environment it's not a reduction happy
positive so it's simply the role in
culpability well okay I mean oh yeah I'm
being pretty informal with the use of
the word green however I do think that
it would be really hard to draw a line
what significant versus what's not
significant I think that if you're
certifying something as a green
technology that's when this becomes an
issue right for a survey that we're
doing we're looking at approaches that
will have an impact and you know a
reduction in energy use is an impact
right even if you're using the same old
gasoline if you use less of it that
should reduce your carbon footprint too
yeah okay whatever oh good good comment
so getting back to this thing about Asia
oh you know you'll see policies in every
asia market and i just picked three
countries to show i meana is a has a
number of major programs and it's
interesting that they want to increase
hybrid and EV autos note carefully not
to fifteen percent of the market but
fifteen percent of their domestic
production that's interesting seeing as
how they haven't been making them right
oh so you've got that they're doubling
the long-distance high-speed rail that
they've got and they're significantly
increasing the size of the Beijing metro
rail which if you've been in traffic in
Beijing is certainly a good idea in
South Korea I was fascinated by you know
increasing the rail share of total
transport and increasing the share of
bicycles as a percent
of total transport from one-point-two
percent to fifteen percent okay I'm
guessing some of those may include
electric bicycle especially on exactly
the Electra munition bike now fact in
many places in Asia particularly in
second-tier city of city in China right
the electric buggies you see electrify m
a dominating factor if you look at the
percentage wise one out of ten people in
channel have a electrical pipe yeah and
the interesting thing is that the
electrified Muslim now runs with another
green that sa matter young man if I all
the ninety-five percent on that SFA's
battery and that this is really one of
my biggest environmental opportunity
exactly in the future is what to do with
old batteries not only lead acid but you
know nickel cadmium and so forth right
metal hydride batteries oh but that's
great so one out of ten people in China
means 130 million people or so I
remember recently seeing a big sign of
advertisement on the street in China for
a solar power charging station for your
electric bicycle so that's yeah this is
definitely something to pay attention to
Korea had probably developed more of an
automobile infrastructure earlier than
China has and so I it will be
interesting to see if they can get
people out of their cars and into
bicycles in Korea I wanted to throw in
Malaysia because Malaysia is one of
those countries you might not
immediately think of but they're already
in phase 2 where they're running trials
out on the streets with electric
vehicles um and they're also very active
in promoting standards for electric
vehicle charging
we tend to be very passive in regard to
technology standards in the US and for
something like charging stations are
charging speeds and technologies for
electric vehicles it really makes sense
to have a world standard this is an area
to watch for so also i think that you
know i'd like to mention that there are
some areas in which asia has already
taken a significant lead over other
areas of the world so the very first
really truly high-speed rail was
introduced commercially in japan in 1964
now if you go back and look there were
German high-speed rail technologies that
go back to the 1930s but at that point
they defined high speed is about 120
kilometers an hour so the first Japanese
trained the series Oh ran at 220 km/h
and they've pushed it up now so that
their operating speed is 300 kilometers
an hour and the design is rated at
three-thirty France came in the US has
had one there are a lot of European
technologies that fit in and are
interoperable with the tgv oh but really
kind of the next major move forward was
the KTX and in Korea and you know it's
rated at 305 km/h right that's the
service speed and it's you know the
design is rated at three-thirty China
introduced high-speed rail in 2007 and
are they running them over 300
kilometers an hour now after the traffic
accident did they cut it back to 300
seems to me like I was on the truck I
was on the train last month from
Shanghai to Hangzhou and I thought that
I saw it go up to 320 but when I was
looking at my source that said 300 so if
it is rated at 380 oh but they slowed it
down because of the signaling problem
that led to a bad accident last year and
Taiwan has a high speed rail system that
is running at 300 kilometers an hour
gotta have pictures right so the picture
up at the top left that's the Korean
train the KTX the top right are two
models of more recent Japanese
Shinkansen bottom left is the Taiwan
high-speed rail and the bottom right is
the Chinese high-speed rail in fact I
took that picture in December last year
so yeah that's in the in the station
inside Shanghai Oh any questions so far
the extent of the network that issue is
trains car yeah I don't have the data
right with me but I'll you know the
Chinese network has been growing at just
breakneck speed is possible to go all
the way from Beijing down to southern
China now using high-speed rail and so
you know it's been growing very fast
most of the main islands of Japan are
already connected by I speed rail they
got a real head start right from 1964
and from Taiwan it's it's a line mostly
from Taipei down to the south end of the
island oh so these are significant these
are not just small showcases these are
really heavily used so I did here just
this way
that one hundred percent of the non
automobile passenger traffic between the
city of Tokyo in the city of Nagoya goes
by rail the airlines have zero percent
of and about eighty-seven percent of the
traffic between Tokyo and Osaka goes by
rail so that the airlines really have
about twelve or thirteen percent I seem
real isn't trained that happens a will
is you're counting kilometers probably
is I mean you the system in Europe is
pretty big right but time is a very
large country and I think they have more
room to expand in terms of kilometers to
grow and do you have any insight into
why 300 km/h why that limit is is sort
of been is it self imposed for almost 50
years oh well actually the japanese
version rated at three thirty years from
about year 2007 okay and that technology
was exported to Taiwan the Taiwan train
really is based on Japanese technology
China got its technology for its
high-speed rail from multiple sources
and the earlier versions of the Chinese
rail trains you can tell whether it
comes from a Japanese Shinkansen or a
siemens design or a design from
bombardier right so they have they had
multiple sources for their technology in
China but they're developing their own
for the next generation the issue i
think is probably as much noise for the
people around the track as it is the
ability of the track to carry something
going that fast I think that has been
people in the railroad business have
told me that that has kept a lid on the
speed
so they're developing this new maglev
superconducting maglev line in Japan
that will go up around 550 or 600
kilometers an hour eighty-nine percent
of the thing is not just underground but
deep underground more than 40 metres
underground which will cost them five
trillion yen over 30 years so you know
seventy billion dollars in today's
dollars okay so yeah pictures any other
questions while we're here go ahead
trains a more economical than airplanes
in terms of energy time and money great
questions and you see that i have this
down here right right oh my
understanding is that a japanese
Shinkansen takes just about the same
amount of equivalent of of fuel
equivalent per kilometer as a Boeing 747
however the Boeing 747 will hold 400
people in the Shinkansen will hold a
thousand so if it's running close to
capacity is very efficient oh you know I
think that compared to the automobile
it's a whole lot more efficient in terms
of moving people around and the sources
of energy depending on where you're
getting your energy from you know that's
the secret behind anything electric is
where you're getting your energy from if
if you're going back to fossil fuel
plants it doesn't look as green as it
did if you are not using fossil fuel
crime okay good questions go ahead she
gossiped Siemens involve you yeah are
they right is there only does three
companies the Navy streets there's like
a dozen I mean if you could look at
Wikipedia for high-speed train and
you'll find like a list of 20 of these
things and you know now there are
technologies coming out of Sweden there
are technologies coming out of
there are technologies coming out of all
sorts of places so yeah these are these
are the principal service lines okay
yeah Zeman's makes was making the one
behind China so there there there a big
player in this other questions okay
let's move on a little bit and talk
about Evie's you may be interested to
know that in 1891 there were ten times
as many electric vehicles on the road as
there were gasoline-powered vehicles and
there were even electric-powered um you
know all sorts of interesting kind of
v's back during that period but the real
issue was that you couldn't charge them
and so they were very they were limited
to city use you couldn't charge them
outside the city and they didn't have
arranged to go more than just you know a
few miles inside the city the other
thing that really kicked off the
gasoline-powered car was the invention
of the self starter in 1913 until you
could have a good starter for the car
gasoline car was not going to work very
well but that fit into the sudden mass
production of oil you know it all
happened kind of at the same time and
arguably the oil industry has had a
negative effect on the development of
electric vehicles since then oh that's
you know but who wrote the book on the
the ev1 that GM tried to produce and
actually had it on the market for a year
to a rather controversial book I
remember and movie yeah but look what
happened since the late 1990s Toyota
brought the Prius out in 1997 in the
next year dees on and unveiled not only
an electric vehicle but one that used a
lithium-ion battery
back in 1997 that was really remarkable
lithium-ion batteries had a bad habit of
catching fire and so you know the fact
that they were able to do this was
pretty impressive and of course the leaf
is now commercial honda has had a fuel
cell hybrid vehicle of since 2008 you
can lease the thing if you live down in
Los Angeles there are even three
hydrogen fueling stations in the Los
Angeles area toyota has a rav4 that's a
fuel cell hybrid that they're about to
put out on the pure electric vehicle
rav4 is going to be made in the Fremont
plant down here next to the Tesla's so
you know that will make that plant very
efficient so suddenly you see an awful
lot of action from the Japanese car
companies in the mid-late 1990s with
regard to electric vehicles and Hyundai
has a very big program now for
developing small scale vehicles and
electric vehicles a number of the
Chinese companies are involved in this
so yeah electric vehicles is another
area in which Asia has really had the
lead over the US for quite some time any
comments on this slide vectors views
there are a lot of national project kind
of things where people will develop a
particular technology I remember about
ten years ago the Japanese government
announced a 500 million dollar a fuel
cell technology not specific for
vehicles but it was a fuel cell
technology national study project and
the closest thing I'd say that that's
equivalent to is it like a big DARPA
grant program here and uh it typically
would go to the industrial sector four
not the academic sector though other
questions okay so some areas too I think
are reasons why to watch Asia I think
that environmental consciousness has
actually been a big part of the Japanese
market for years and years and years and
it is now a huge part of Chinese
government policy so there is an acute
awareness of the need to improve the
transportation system you're looking at
demonstrated R&D strengths and complex
system design hardware and software
systems and especially some areas like
robotics I think are very likely to be
interesting the next time around with
with vehicles battery technologies are
actually mostly coming from Asia now and
the other thing to watch is the business
experience that Asian companies already
have with new transportation related to
technologies so the very first Boeing 80
787 Dreamliner went to AAA and I've seen
the thing at the tokyo haneda airport I
haven't been able to ride on one yet but
I see it just about every time I'm there
now in contrast United takes its first
787 this month and they made a big
announcement about it on the plane last
week Oh Evergreen Line shipping is a
shipping line out of Taiwan that is
devoted to green technologies and
Trenton maritime transportation so you
know they have been implementing a
number of I would say more incremental
innovations oh you're probably familiar
with the commercial maglev line between
the Shanghai Airport and a sort of
inconvenient place in the middle of
Shanghai
it's a 32 kilometers atrae nuns up to
about Oh what 500 kilometers an hour
takes eight minutes so you know they're
actually running the thing and when you
see companies that have experienced
actually running these things that's
really valuable you can do an awful lot
of stuff in the lab and develop
prototypes but when you actually take it
out real time it has to have a
reliability factor that's a lot more
than you would tolerate in the lab Japan
railways has developed a completely
paperless ticketing system and you will
still see you know paper tickets but
this ticketing system is now being used
for electronic cash all around the
country that's a major step toward green
Oh other examples I have a feeling
there's a lot I could have mentioned and
there's probably people in the room who
think of them Suika or go so much a Hong
Kong has to offer this caucus is part
yeah would you like to sleep so you kind
of thing yeah and the bays been running
it they've been regulars yeah yeah oh we
just finally got the clipper card here
right go ahead I think it was amazing
thing is the electric bike yeah each
other yes oh no you know who is the main
maker for that or is it a bunch of
different yeah interesting thing that
it's all mostly you know small small
players ok provision there the other
interesting happy that government is the
hate and the lovely decision because
because it's caused a lot of problems to
them and also potential solutions
environmentally but also on the other
hand it's it's a solution to reduce the
emission yeah one of the things to watch
out for about an electric bicycle they
do great in flat places but a lot of
them don't
the power to get up a hill and that has
been a negative factor for a lot of that
technology now I've seen some I've seen
some new new designs that would actually
deal with the hills in San Francisco so
yeah back in the back then strangest in
austell Victoria has biggest market
places which are on the subways so
people who go back don't have to go to
the market they can do mobile shopping
so it's not only fueling actually good
thinking example one way you could even
just take a picture with your smartphone
and buy it right yeah that that really
is a nice green kind of approach and in
the broad sense of if you're in the
involved in moving from point A to point
B it's very much a supporting technology
good so I didn't mention India in any of
my slides so far but I think that in the
transportation sector India actually has
the second longest number of rail miles
to China now this is not high speed rail
this is just total rail models China
actually has more than just about
anybody except I think the u.s. still
has more go ahead kind of related to
that being green in the sense of not
having to go somewhere which which I
think one other thing with Asia is is
strengthened broadband and someone
networking test before she came yeah so
yeah I think the communications
infrastructure maybe that should have
been thrown up there in the R&D strength
is our communications infrastructure
also a very well developed wireless
sensor networks there are probably more
sensors per kilometer in Japanese roads
and anywhere else in the world they will
tell you immaculate amazing amounts of
information that just make you more
frustrated about not getting places
faster go ahead
in Japan they actually actively monitor
the traffic we're monitoring mobile want
a lot of phones as they move through the
transportation network so we can figure
out our salary to manage schedule that's
true now actually we have a commercial
service here that's don't vary the same
thing weighs WA ze is a very interesting
little company where you can sign up for
it and use your cell phone's GPS signal
to give a real-time indication of how
fast you're moving if you're commuting
and then it will turn out
recommendations to other ways users
about what roads to take so yeah and I
do think that is a maybe in parallel the
same kind of project as going on in
Japan so what's in it for the u.s. I
think that we do need to learn from Asia
examples oh you know what would a
high-speed rail system really looked
like in the Northeast Corridor and I was
talking with the railway expert earlier
this week and he pointed out that the
whole approach to safety in the US has
been crashworthiness so that the people
who are in a crash are basically
protected or as the whole situation in
Japan has been crash avoidance now there
has been no fatal accident on the
Shinkansen since nineteen sixty-four
they just haven't been accidents oh and
so I think looking at the asia examples
would be really interesting i am very
concerned that we need to be a little
bit more proactive in looking at
technology standards i'm aware of a
major japanese government / industry
effort to put together charging
standards for electric vehicles and
they're going around and trying to sell
it here and i have a feeling that the
companies here just sort of not really
paying attention
other market opportunities also involve
business business or technology partners
not just selling in those markets and
certainly it involves looking at global
competition what is going to happen to
the foreign automakers in China as China
builds up its domestic EV production I
think that's a matter that if you're
connected to the auto industry need to
be concerned about and yeah it's not too
early to look to the next generation of
cool things things that are really early
on the horizon the maglev is probably a
really good example using airships
lighter than air ships for freight
transport across the Pacific taking
advantage of the jet stream is one of
the crazier ideas that I've heard
recently so there are all kinds of
things like this so what we've got
coming up in the series next week uh mr.
Anoeta who is the Silicon Valley
representative for the new energy and
industrial technology development
organization is going to talk about
Japanese government policies and
investments in green transportation
technology they're running a number of
very large smart grid projects including
one in New Mexico as well as one in
malaga spain in which they're looking at
combining electric vehicles in the grid
for additional power storage one of
their projects is also in toyota city
which is not too surprising um two weeks
from today a professor from a japanese
university who is also the CEO of a
company called sim drive is coming in
and sim drive has not just a new
electric motor but it's an in wheel
electric motor so potentially you could
even convert old gasoline-powered cars
to a car with an N wheel electric motor
we'll see professor John is coming from
Ching hua university to talk about some
research that they've just done on
intelligent transportation and Beijing
in November one mr. Kondo the Boeing 787
makes extensive use of carbon fiber
composite materials it's very strong and
very light and it's probably saving
something like twenty five or thirty
percent of the energy use of the
airplane so he's coming in to talk about
this not only for airplane applications
but for how you might be able to put
that into automobiles in subsequent
sessions i'm working with a company
coming from china to talk about
scrubbing emissions from marine
transport i'm talking with a couple of
airlines about seeing if we can get
somebody to come and talk about this
whole system this total system we're
looking at a number of other different
kind of areas oh but that's where we are
at as we stop right now i'm very happy
to take your questions and discuss what
your ideas and interests are in this
regard thanks for your attention go
ahead yeah go ahead quick points in the
digital version is made to york times or
the article about bicycle helmets yeah
and the fact that they are a significant
inhibit or to fall well your point about
in America we avoided we try to protect
individual crash yeah survivability and
so forth but in Paris and London and
number of other major cities around the
world they are actively a bit of failing
to encourage or enforce helmet rules
really my dad won't ride a bicycle
probably because the helpless owner air
but that's another matter she's not here
but so this helmet thing they're clearly
so people there the head of bicycle
transportation in portland or seattle is
actively trying to move away from the
helmet requirement and they're getting
spit out in a number of these cities
they're getting spectacular increases in
the number of people willing to play so
that's kind of interesting what about
personal behavior level although it is i
wonder if there's any kind of solution
to making it more safe without a helmet
yeah yeah i actually just saw an article
maybe a month ago it was basically a
foot that packed around kind of your
neck comment it have accelerometers that
would call it to weight ratio your
airbag or how's your hip that's good
whether you technology so a little
taller than my eyes to look a lot more
socially acceptable personally i think
it makes a lot of sense to wear a helmet
because you don't look like you're right
thing after that yeah guys continuing
with a bike helmet thing I guess being a
poignant London for a number of years
they become rooms with spicy well don't
wearing a bike helmet a couple of years
ago now try and promote this all I get
it also has been a study conducted that
says that drivers give you more space if
you're not wearing a helmet because they
presume is you are wearing a helmet you
know you're doing for so there may give
us space why don't you say good yeah is
not debatable but
knowing what you're doing apparent
you're such a couple of comments you go
first okay yeah what I want to play off
that because there are several studies
that in the United States on school
buses and the conclusion was that if
they loud young children of the muscles
to wear seatbelts the bus drivers would
be less cautious so in the United States
school buses at least as of five or six
years ago don't have seatbelts because
of the driver be more careful and it's
like really enforced that way super good
protected back in the back is the
California I speed rail will awaken the
head actually Alan we co-produced the
program a couple of days ago would we
co-produced a program a couple of days
ago about kind of high-speed rail and
investing for the future and so on and
so forth and junior central that runs
the Shinkansen between Tokyo and Osaka
has invested in several projects none of
which are in California and the the
projects are in the Northeast Corridor
and there's also they're also investing
in a project in texas between dallas and
houston but i think that i'm trying to
put together i don't have all my
speakers lined up i'm trying to put
together a panel session about what
California should learn from asian
high-speed rail to be the closing
session of this series so if I'm
successful with that will have but
better answers he know he scored over
how can they don't have a high-speed
rail for all these years well they have
is this is our they have this Excel of
that actually can run about 240
kilometers an hour so what what's that
about 120 miles an hour or actually I
guess 150 Oh
I think part of the issue is the whole
question of who's going to invest in the
infrastructure who's going to invest in
the track Axela the passenger trains in
the US are tenants they do not own the
track there are tenants they do not own
the track the freight companies own the
track and Amtrak is a tenant they pee
use fee right for using the rails so
that has meant that the government has
been less willing to put in major bucks
into building track beds especially
elevated track beds or you know
underground track that would really make
high-speed rail a lot more efficient I
think that's been part of the difficulty
is the public-private division of labor
did you in line business to the personal
rapid transport I'm thinking about
comment cars but you know when you go on
highway if you want to go to long
distance maybe there's a cable that
tethers out and it yeah I know what
you're talking about and I think that
that's a great futuristic things in
between here and there is probably the
autonomous driving car where you could
have four or five people in the car but
as soon as you get out onto the freeway
the car takes over and you're no longer
driving now honestly there are two main
things that work against that one is
people's obstinacy for liking to drive
okay I mean this is any kind of a new
technology that requires a major
behavior change is dicey until you
actually deploy it you never know
whether people are going to like it or
not so who's going to spend the money to
deploy it the second thing is legal
liability if there are private companies
involved they will be very concerned
about what kind of liability protection
they have in case something in the
system goes wrong and some I gets killed
in the
yes especially that's a real negative
factor for real sort of different ways
of moving people around system and i
understanding you can have a china with
that you know do you um expand but you
know that the US since you can the
reason is a are you investigated about
year 2000 2001 about IPC for us and
japan market and obviously if you don't
have a focus on that 2010 and i want to
know how's it going not only that us
return these asian countries especially
also and that I'm us because Google is
you know developing the remote control
car so medium taxi okay so intelligent
transportation systems are kind of a
specific domain of Technology kind of
like artificial intelligence is a
specific domain of technology like
artificial intelligence it disappeared
and it's come back before anybody even
noticed so the the top down plans for
developing intelligent transportation
systems sort of didn't really have the
demand side that would make it
immediately implementable as business so
it got to the government project level
there were a bunch of different
government projects there are still some
going on here in the US as well as in
other places but what has happened is
everybody carrying around a mobile phone
right and the kind of informal
intelligent transportation systems
networks so I got into a taxi and Tokyo
those in Fukuoka it wasn't even in Tokyo
last week and on the display which
usually has a GPS it shows where every
taxi in the fleet is there to at the
station there are three by the airport
there are two day you know and that's a
pretty intelligent transportation system
right so it's come back without people
noticing just like AI has come back as
advanced analytics
I did people disagreeing with me on that
go ahead Richard you had the battery
expert from Tesla a thriving art and
what we learned from his presentations
that they made the decision to use
laptop batteries lithium ion batteries
because their availability and cost
presumably and they put in parallel
something like 6,000 to them yeah has
that battery technology gods more
specific too easy is that that seems to
me to be actually it's not exactly like
a laptop the form factor is but the
content the energy delivery is different
from a standard double a battery that
you buy it looks a lot like a double a
battery and you're right there and
there's about six thousand eight hundred
of them in the pack and how they did
that because it was a cheaper solution
to get them in a pack like that it was
also a more safe solution because if one
of the batteries goes bad you can
isolate it instead of having the whole
pack blow up right and so I think that
there is a lot of work on batteries for
vehicles that's certainly a major area
that all of the car companies are
looking at and the lithium-ion
technologies have improved a lot be a
battery company as opposed to a car
company the car was just in advertising
mechanism for their battery technology
so have to have the Europeans and the
Japanese and Chinese rush to license
that via not yet really i think that the
kind of battery provision is in the
toyota rav4 since that's coming out of
the same line as the Tesla cars okay go
ahead that work for SpaceX requested I
and they actually use this license maybe
computer with a lot of their technology
from
and CEOs are the same yeah all right not
much good either there was good yeah at
least one company does exist to fall
under the same theme um I think Nissan
has their own like R&D department
battery technology so well the division
of labor is really hard because neat son
has their own R&D division like that
there are Japanese companies like Denzel
and EB den that supply the car companies
kind of like Visteon supplies for and
the real question from the standpoint of
management is who controls the specs it
has gotten to the point where the parent
company the Toyota tends to control the
specs and force its supplier companies
out of really interesting research even
though they've got a lot of the
knowledge in the company and so if the
supplier company and I'm thinking of a
relationship like between Robert Bosch
corporation and the Japanese the German
carmakers right BMW and benz and and
also Volkswagen queer bashas pushing
ahead new technologies and then they're
able to get one of the car companies to
buy it that would be a more productive
situation in Japan go ahead just car
sharing play a role at all in Asia not
nearly as much as you would expect I
mean I'm looking around does anybody
know if if zipcar is tried to go
anywhere in Asia no but it's cheaper to
hire drivers and bicycles so I do that
yeah but I do think is going to happen
is you're going to have inside the major
cities a lot more restrictions on having
cars at all and that is probably going
to not only push you know mass transit
but it would also push car sharing for
the limited number of vehicles allowed
inside the city on the city streets so i
think it's not as far along
it is here but I would say that it's
likely to grow rather quickly other
questions or comments do seemed us shale
gas revolutionary shale shale gas here
in the US the Canadian study in France
we take technology you well okay I think
that um to the extent that shale oil
will be used to make gas which is used
in transportation this fits into the
overall topic oh it's a major source and
it is economic in Canada there's a lot
of concern up in Canada about the
environmental side of that I was just in
Ottawa two weeks ago looking at new
research proposals about this kind of
area and i think that the shale oil is
an interesting stopgap they've also just
announced of their they're taking it out
of the ground in japan now in Akita and
so this is you know hot and it's a new
source and I think it's Japan's first
domestic source of oil yeah but whether
it will really be economical or whether
it might even be a distraction it's kind
of hard to tell I think that moving away
from fossil fuels and toward renewables
is going to be the dominant path for
general energy now in transportation
you've got to get your energy from
somewhere else which means that you know
the internal combustion engine you're
producing the energy on the car instead
of just using stored energy from
whatever source right now
in improving on urban traffic now do you
see admissions and in Kuala Lumpur they
could put in yeah thing they those hard
to walk from that point ank point even
though is really really short because
you're a good killed or no the bog
hopper just like it's not designed for
okay walk now it's very hot he made a
joke and I guess I started this week all
the guys he's on strike because they put
into this new system to put a walk and
free buses and yeah it's really cheap to
get taxi yeah yeah so looking around
Malaysia had a very well described plan
that you know I quoted in that slide and
it is definitely kind of a top down we
will do this sort of approach oh who
knows yeah one more and then let's all
go out and we can continue our
discussion / / refreshments two more go
ahead from the speakers this year I see
that definition of Asia by these classes
mostly I move around really hard for
India okay and Mahindra has a very
interesting Evie program that they're
working on the basic transportation
infrastructure in India is kind of a
disaster and so oh you know that that
that's not moving ahead public sector
stuff doesn't move ahead nearly as well
as private sector things do in India I
looked around we may not be able to have
them come follows a fat and less their
lives alone the local charities get
ignored they're not really low on the
transportation scheme the things Bangkok
is a really interesting place in terms
of looking at the transportation system
and what can be done about it it's also
a very big automobile market Oh
I wasn't able to find anything that I
thought would be like really unusual you
know something that's sort of looking
far enough ahead that would be really
different go ahead whether your
refreshments are going to be served but
for the last two weeks I have been the
proud owner of one of the fastest
electric bicycles in the United States
of America it's custom made locally and
if anyone would like to see it I
probably can't give any people or give
you a chance to play with the
accelerator but it is an interesting
example of the high end of powered ball
scale to wield machine how many how fast
will it go 30 miles an hour Wow and it
will climb Hills I climbed up it okay
okay ah how many cc's ah it's a wife
ring oh yeah hard there's anybody here
from the cook I understand there's a
company incubating in startx here at
Stanford that has kind of like a power
assisted skateboard it's got an in wheel
electric motor yeah yeah yeah I mean
aside from the kind of safety angle of
that I think it's fascinating
fascinating information what's thought
to have some refreshments and keep
honking thank you everybody thank you
you